[Music]
chuck
yes
explainer time always good i got a topic
that we should have done years ago i
don't know why it took us this long to
figure out
we should do it yeah i want to describe
what it's like to die
as you fall into a black hole now are we
recounting a personal experience here
perhaps that could be the reason for the
delay in discussing this
are you sure you're ready for this after
this after this harrowing
one of the highest compliments i ever
got was um i was giving a tour of the
newly built hayden planetarium newly
renovated to seinfeld okay who
who lived across the street so he's a
nate what's the deal with the likes well
right so i just i described the big bang
to him in the first few moments and
right in exquisite detail and he says
it sounds like you were there
i thought man that's a high compliment i
i i'd never forget that that's pretty
funny i'm about to describe
death by black hole and no
i will alert you in advance i was not
there okay but we know the physics of it
and that
that's just as good
okay all right
so
a black hole so you're standing here on
earth all right i am by the way sitting
you are you're sitting on earth and your
feet
are closer to the center of the earth
than the top of your head is okay
do we agree
i will agree i'm not that short so yeah
you have to be really short for that not
to be got to be kind of like a mr potato
head
[Laughter]
just have your feet right at the bottom
of your head right up under you
right up under your neck
i guess mr potato head didn't have a
torso no oh my gosh that's right oh that
is
that is sad yeah it is how come i never
noticed that as i missed potato head was
all head it was all head and feet arms
and feet that was
arm's coming out of the side of his head
that's right arms right
all right so
you can calculate
the strength of earth's gravity at your
feet
and the strength of earth's gravity at
the top of your head and you'll get a
different number
wow
because your feet are closer to the
center of the earth
okay and the closer you are
to an object with gravity
the higher is the gravitational force
operating on you
okay so if i do that for you uh you're
five nine something like that what how
tall are you and so you're five ten i
want seven
you're a big guy so you don't care oh
yeah you're like six three so you don't
give a damn no i'm six two six that's
what i'm saying you know i gave you an
inch
i i was six two in high school i
probably you know got the old man
shrinkage from that so
all right
so i can write down the difference
between those two forces and it's not
going to be very much
so you're not you don't think about it
you don't care about it
it's not much because your height is
small
compared with the radius of the earth
correct radius here it's 4 000 miles and
here you are
you know just under six feet so that's
so we don't think about this
difference
in the gravitational force we don't have
occasion to think about it
but that difference in force has a word
it's called the tidal force
okay
okay now the tidal force of the moon
operating on the earth
the side of the earth facing the moon
feels a stronger gravitational force of
the moon
than the side of the earth that's on the
than the other side of the earth that's
farther away from the moon you can
calculate this
okay
and so the entire earth is stretched
in the direction of the moon
because of this tidal force
the solid earth is stretched
but that's less notable noticeable
because we're walking around on the
solid earth
but what's most noticeable is the oceans
are stretched
and it's called a tidal bulge
all right and so wherever you're going
to find the moon you're going to find a
tidal bulge
elongated
pointing to the moon
it actually doesn't it points ahead of
the moon because we're dragging it
in our as earth rotates but that's a
whole other
explainer that we're going to get into
for now just consider it we're aligned
with the moon okay so now watch
that's because earth is big compared to
the distance between the moon and the
earth okay so that's why
earth is bigger compared to that
distance than you are compared to
earth's radius
right so now watch what happens
let's go let's turn earth into a black
hole
let's just do that okay you know how you
do that you just shrink it
okay as you shrink it
the gravity on the surface goes up
why
you're getting closer to the center of
the earth and it still has all the mass
in this model that i'm describing okay
two things
tell you how much you weigh how far away
you are
and how much mass is tugging on you
right as that happens
your size which is still five feet ten
right
relative to the size that the earth is
becoming
is actually more and more significant
right
because the earth is no longer 4 000
miles in radius
it's correct that radius is shrinking
and shrinking and shrinking so it's
becoming
much closer to
my size as it's correct correct and when
you do the math
the difference in the force between your
feet and the top of the head
gets greater and greater and greater
okay
so now
let's
fall into a black hole
and describe what happens
okay okay so here you are
falling into a black towards a black
hole
[Music]
there's no air so no one's hearing you
damn it okay
you're just catching flies with your
open mouth there that's all right
so meteor particles so you've you're
falling feet first let's give you a feet
first dive
and
the tidal force is slowly getting
greater and greater
and initially it feels kind of good
who doesn't love a good stretch oh
right best spot ever i know and then you
realize wait a minute that stretch is
not only not abating it's getting worse
uh-oh we're getting medieval
yeah exactly you can't meet evil this
ain't cool
don't make me get medieval on your ass
i had not thought about how medieval
this is
because you look at the machines they
had it's like
what were they thinking let me tell you
something
somebody was staying up at night
thinking about ways
to torture and kill people because
that is effed up yeah they excelled
beyond
you know imagination i heard there's
another one where they disembowel you
and so that hurts enough and then they
take your intestines out and put it on
the fire
so that
you're not only in pain from being cut
open your organs are in pain
after they've removed it because it's
still you know your intestines are all
stringy right yeah so they're still
connected to you and so
and then you know what draw being drawn
in quarter it is you know what that is
um is that the one where they put you on
the horse the four horses yeah four
horses right so
so a horse to each limb
and
then they'll they give they'll score you
right they'll just just so that you you
cut more easily oh man
we must perforate him now
[Laughter]
so you do that and when the four horses
run away you were in four different
pieces
no matter what you are in four different
pieces by the time that's done well
really five because there's a torso
laying on the ground no no no no no
that's not how it works no i thought you
i thought you know
each limb
okay so if i if so if three limbs are
pulled off the fourth limb is still
attached to the rest of your body no i
thought it was four like four horses one
for each limb and i know
what i'm saying is
your body doesn't rip apart
simultaneously okay god okay so one
horse rips off one arm oh no one other
leg and then another leg and one arm has
slightly more muscle tissue there holds
on to the rest of the torso i did not
know this is how this thing worked this
is i mean you just made it ten times
worse oh i'm saying that what you
described the limbs would have to be
equally
attached with a
forced
force tissue exactly okay
equally and simultaneously pulled in
exactly the right angles exactly for
them to pull off all at the same instant
and this is not how that works uh that's
my point you ruined my fantasy as well
okay sorry that you just dropped down in
the middle and yeah
i just drop in the middle and i'm
sitting there like an oblong you know
then you're not being quartered you're
being dismembered that's different
you're right okay so this is all nice
preamble for what's about to happen to
you uh-oh okay so your feet first
falling towards the black hole okay the
stretch feels good
but then it becomes unrelenting
because your height is now a bigger and
bigger fraction
of the distance you are to the center of
the black hole
all right so now
you start sliding in and
what happens oh my gosh the tidal force
exceed there will be a point
where the tidal force exceeds
the
molecular forces
that keep your body attached as one
piece oh no my molecular bonds
you're a molecular bond so you will snap
into two parts that's nasty
and i and since all the forces are
operating uniformly across your body
it's not like a horse yanking on one
thing or another i did a calculation i'd
have to probably have to speak with some
physiologist about this but i think
you'll initially snap at your lower
spine
okay so those are the two bits
now these those two parts of you
continue to feel
the tidal force okay
so they stretch
okay
and so
your bottom half
snaps into two pieces all right your
upper torso snaps into two pieces and as
best as i can judge that would be at the
base of your neck
okay
now your brain is still working you can
in principle see this
okay this happens pretty fast
and by the way they did these
experiments from what i've read in um in
the french revolution with the
guillotine right if you're gonna be
guillotined you might as well help out
science right so yeah with your head on
the ground before your brain really
knows that it can't get oxygen from
blood
do your eyes still work okay
and so i think they did experiments
where they hold up one finger two finger
and you blink if you saw two fingers or
one finger just for that because your
eyes go straight to your brain they
don't need your torso
for none of that okay
so
people were messed up in the past
all right so now you're in four pieces
and they continue to feel the title
force and then you go from 2 to 4 to 8
to 16 to 32 to 64 and this continues
until you are a stream
of atoms
like a train of atoms
pouring down
to the singularity and that's not the
worst of it
go ahead
okay
the fabric of space and time
funnels funnels
and gets narrower and narrower
because it ends up at a singularity
so whatever horizontal volume you
occupied
you become extruded through the fabric
of space
like toothpaste through a tube
this form of death
has a name
and it's called
spaghettification okay
well i mean i can't believe something
that
horrific
could have such a delicious name
how did this happen
so
i many years ago wrote a book called
death by black hole
and i thought the book would do well and
the publisher looked kind of askance at
me like no we don't think this is going
to do well i said dude look at the title
come on now and so they they they didn't
print enough copies when it was first
released and it sold out in a day wow
and then the the this is before we had
like amazon and everything so when you
sell off the shelves there's nothing
there to buy and but in that week it hit
the best seller list but it became a
minimum best seller right it hit number
15
for one week
that's a minimum best seller but it
would have stayed there if there's more
books available more copies yeah so i
lorded that over the publisher ever
since um but anyhow death by black hole
and i describe this but also
i want to share with you
a poem
that i composed
about death by black hole may i yeah a
place dil okay i'm not a poet so dare i
call it a poem i'll call it a rhyme
okay
so righty here it is okay
in your feet first dive to this cosmic
abyss
you will not survive
because you will not miss
the tidal forces of gravity will create
quite a calamity when you're stretched
head to toe
are you sure you want to go your body's
atoms you'll see them will enter one by
one
the singularity will eat him
and you won't be having fun
that i have to say
uh is the scariest dr seuss book i have
ever heard
good night timmy
[Laughter]
behave tomorrow
oh snap all right we out of time chuck
okay uh that was cool that was more than
you ever cared to know about death by
black hole i love it
there you go by the way a quick thing if
you come in in a trajectory where you
don't head to the singularity
then you can bypass the singularity and
you won't get torn apart
and so that and then you can open up to
another spacetime that black holes are
famous theoretically famous for
producing
and so i had we didn't talk about
relativity in that
in that account but all that goes on
inside of a black hole i thought i'd
tell you that
yeah that's right
all right this has been yet another star
talk explainer with chuck knight neil
degrasse tyson your personal
astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]
you